magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman yesterday
morning the ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky spoke to a
not really a joint session but members
of both the u.s house and the u.s senate
and made a number of requests in that
speech including that the united states
put in place
and enforce a no-fly zone over ukraine
which is
the the enforcement of a no-fly zone is
a significant escalation and significant
american involvement and asked for a
number of additional weapon systems and
um additional
uh armaments and supplies and indeed
later in the day yesterday
president joe biden announced
an additional 800 million dollars in
military assistance to ukraine including
drones and air defense systems now we're
going to go through the politics of it
and we're going to go through the
hypocritical reactions to it but let's
first listen to joe biden making this
announcement yesterday it'll include 7
000 small arms machine guns shotguns
grenade launchers to equip the
ukrainians including the brave women and
men who are defending their cities as
civilians and they're on the countryside
as well
and we're and we and as well as the
ammunition artillery and mortar rounds
to go with small arms 20 million rounds
in total 20 million rounds
this will include drones which
which
demonstrates our commitment to sending
our most cutting-edge systems to ukraine
first so sending drones is quite a big
deal
the breakdown of the 800 million dollar
package is 800 stinger anti-aircraft
systems 2 000 javelin a thousand light
anti-armor weapons and 6000 at4
anti-armor systems
100 tactical unmanned aerial systems
drones
100 grenade launchers 5000 rifles a
thousand pistols machine guns shotguns
20 million rounds 25 000 sets of body
armor and 25 000 helmets now there's a
bunch of different things to talk about
here first and foremost
um
isn't it weird that joe biden didn't say
but i need you to do me a favor though
before sending the stuff okay that's a
joke but in all seriousness the people
on the right the trumpists now
criticizing joe biden for doing this
are the same people cheering
and agreeing with trump
that he armed ukraine when he was
president
despite the fact that trump withheld the
aid trying to strong-arm zelinski into
announcing an investigation into joe
biden and ultimately was sort of
forced
uh as it were to release the military
aid because of what we learned about him
trying to hold hostage the aid over dirt
on joe biden so there's like three
layers there first of all trump wants
credit for arming ukraine okay
but
the reality is he withheld that aid and
released it because he got caught trying
to blackmail them but then when joe
biden also sends a bunch more stuff to
ukraine the very same people who say it
was good that trump armed them don't say
that it's good that biden is arming them
now that's the hypocrisy we've gotten
that won't surprise you that there's a
bunch of hypocrisy out on the table
in all seriousness
we really are in a proxy war here now
it's not a proxy on both sides sometimes
when people say proxy war they mean
it's a war between a and b
being supported by c and d in this case
it's the united states and other
countries
uh sort of fighting a proxy war against
russia and russia is in and of itself
fighting the war now
you don't have to say that just because
it's a proxy war it's good or it's bad
you could argue well
ukraine is in the right here or at least
russia is in the wrong for their
invasion and ukraine should defend
itself
but i don't want my country's troops on
the ground that's the um commitment that
joe biden has made and so the only way
really for a government to support that
there's really two ways for a government
to support ukraine one by sending stuff
and two by trying to sanction russia or
negotiate with russia to get them to
stop and to some degree the united
states is doing all three of those
things although not necessarily in the
proportions that everybody would like to
see the counterpoint would be the u.s
should have no involvement whatsoever
and so um like with many of these things
when it comes to geopolitics foreign
relations war etc
there are some
in the commentary space
who like to use a term
and immediately ascribe an implied
morality to it it's a proxy war
oh okay but so
is it the right thing or the wrong thing
to do
are we supporting ukraine in the
appropriate ways or in inappropriate
ways and there's really no correct
answer it is without a doubt that russia
as the aggressor
um should be repelled by any means with
which ukraine can do it and part of
ukraine having the means to do it is
coming from western nations joe biden
said no boots on the ground he seems
committed to it we've been saying
what about drones are drones going over
and indeed 100 drones are going over let
me know what you think and it's very
interesting because there are people on
i mean on the right it's whacked what's
going on i i barely even care what's
happening on the right in terms of the
discourse because it's so
bad faith and and sort of worthless for
lack of a better term even on the left
there are contingents in my audience who
are saying we should do nothing nothing
nothing nothing
okay if a nato country is invaded then
we meet our responsibilities as nato
members but nothing beyond that that's
one side
the other side are people who email me
and they say david
biden was wrong to say no boots on the
ground this is a war worth fighting and
we should be fighting it with everything
we've got and that includes sending
troops and then it's everything in
between in my audience i would love to
hear from you about it
um let's see how to even introduce this
next story
it's become a popular talking point now
that we are um 20-ish days or so
into the russian invasion of ukraine
it's become a popular talking point for
defenders of the former president donald
trump to say
putin didn't do this under trump he's
doing this under joe biden because trump
was strong
and putin respected trump
whereas biden is weak and vladimir putin
does not respect
joe biden
and
when in the past i've talked about this
i've said to you that's speculative
that's that's completely speculative
trump has never been seen as
particularly strong by any world leader
and
russia and putin
preferred trump over hillary so it
doesn't really make sense that russia
would prefer
the stronger person they would probably
prefer the weaker person it just sort of
makes sense so it was kind of a
speculative claim and
when i came to you and talked to you
about it and i said sirs sirs and mams
uh and i said uh that's that's
speculative and if we want to speculate
it's much more plausible to me
that the reason russia didn't invade
ukraine under trump was because russia
didn't feel the need because generally
they were more pleased with what the
international community
spotlighted on the united states was
doing with regard to russia at the time
they're both speculative but one
conforms to the facts much more closely
now you can even go further in that
analysis and say it's not even really
true
that russia did nothing to ukraine when
trump was president because they
maintained their their presence in the
donetsk and luhansk and continued
supporting the separatists there okay so
it's like not even really true but among
speculation it made more sense that the
reason putin didn't do more when trump
was president was because he didn't
really feel that he needed to because he
was more pleased with trump as president
okay
we now have
a new perspective
and it comes from donald trump's own
former national security adviser john
bolton and john bolton says putin saw
trump doing a lot of his work for him
so he chose not to invade ukraine
bolton's opinion
matches
much of our speculation
business insider goes on to say
trump considered withdrawing the u.s
from nato while he was president that's
something that is very uh uh you know
putin likes that
bolton said it's one of the reasons that
putin did not invade ukraine during
trump's time in office
and it really makes perfect sense this
was our suspicion and it makes a lot of
sense now i think i would be doing
an incomplete
uh discussion of this if i didn't
mention
john bolton bolton's despicable of
course and i know that the revolutionary
left any time you say hey the cia says
this or bolton said that
they say
you
corporatist
establishment stooge
believing what these people say
uncritically no we're not doing that uh
it's natural and correct to see john
bolton as a despicable person uh one of
the great architects of the war in iraq
in 2003 all of it of course of course of
course and he screwed around during the
impeachment he could have testified but
he opted not to and uh he has personal
knowledge of how disastrous trump was
and now all of a sudden he's sort of
like giving us the goods but at the same
time you can understand that reality
about john bolton
and still recognize that what he's
saying matches up with much of what was
publicly known and it conforms to common
sense as well
both can be true and so i am not someone
who
uncritically accepts anything that
horrible
neocon
uh trump uh uh um former trump uh
employees
say
but
i believe that it's completely plausible
what bolton is saying and it really
makes a lot of sense and it was our
sense from the beginning is bolton the
good guy no but why would he lie about
this specifically i i don't really know
i don't really know he's certainly a
warhawk opportunist you know piece of
crap
who
has repeatedly lobbied the u.s to go to
war with iran and he looks out for
himself his financial interest etc i
just don't think he's lying here i think
what he's making what he's saying makes
perfect sense he's been an enabler he's
uh laid cover for
a corrupt war in iraq and all of these
different things but we suspected that
that explanation made at least more
sense than don jr's explanation that
daddy's so strong
that vlady didn't invade that
explanation did not make any sense
because trump was not strong
and in fact you have to look only at the
sanctions i mean hillary clinton has
been sanctioned and banned by putin uh
and russia
um she's not president or she's not
doing anything right now and trump's not
on that sanction list so the the the
evidence uh all points to what john
bolton happens to be saying if you
disagree with his assessment
by all means i want to hear from you and
you can find me on twitter
at d pacman let me know your thoughts
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar that's why
you should check out our longtime
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon tastes
exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid
but magic spoon has zero grams of sugar
14 grams of protein and only four net
carbs so it's perfect if you're doing
low carb or keto or if like me you just
try to limit your sugar intake you can
build your own variety pack with flavors
like cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
david pakman show is funded primarily by
viewers like you podcast listeners like
you by our community at the end of the
day and the number one
mechanism for that funding is the david
pakman show membership program which you
can find at joinpacman.com not only do
you get the daily bonus show an extra
show every day that alex jones really
doesn't like oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
you also get access to the commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show
and they're available
six hours earlier to our members roughly
five six five and a half six five hours
40 minutes earlier yeah uh then up for
everybody else you can sign up at join
pacman.com you can use the coupon code
wow 22 if you would like a discount
let's talk about disinformation the um
russian invasion of ukraine
provides an opportunity for some
introspection which we want to do right
now
it's very easy and common for us in the
united states
to hear oh the north korean people are
being told this and they believe it
or the russian people are being told
this
and they believe it like
russia's invasion of ukraine is a moral
and correct action because
it's all neo-nazis in ukraine and
there's biolabs and they want to be
russian anyway you know whatever and we
see we hear that and many of us say
these people how do they fall for this
stuff you know we're we're americans we
don't fall for this sort of sort of
stuff but actually many americans fall
for exactly this this sort of stuff so
the context is how could they really
believe that here is julia yaffi on
msnbc saying hey you know what it
happens in the united states too take a
listen to this very very interesting
discussion with stephanie rule you know
every time i'm asked by americans you
know do russians really believe this
stuff like how can they believe this
stuff as if we don't have the same thing
happening here you have what 40 percent
of the population that of the american
population that was convinced just in
one year
that donald trump actually won the 2020
election right the russians have been
subjected to this kind of disinformation
for far far longer so it shouldn't be
all that surprising americans fall for
it too pretty easily
this is a really this is a big topic
when one of the earliest stories i
remember where i said
wow people just believe stuff without
evidence all the time
was in the aftermath of the invasion to
the iraq war of 2003 there was it's
ingrained in my mind like it was just
yesterday i remember covering it in the
early days of the show in 2005 2006
um there was a study done by pipa
which asked americans basically three
fundamental questions who did 911
are were wnd weapons of mass destruction
found in iraq and does the world
generally approve or disapprove of the
american invasion of iraq and we found
the study found that
fox news viewers people who primarily
got their information from fox news were
far more likely to believe yes
we did find weapons of mass destruction
in iraq when we did not
they were far more likely to believe yes
saddam was responsible for 9 11. and
they were far more likely to believe
that the global community approved of
the american invasion of iraq which it
did not which it did not that it was
factually untrue
uh and nothing has really changed in
fact it's kind of gotten worse with
social media echo chambers and filter
bubbles in the last couple of years yes
of course the trump one thing so many
republicans falling for trump actually
was the winner of the 2020 election but
also beliefs about vaccines right uh
much of the country believes the
pandemic is over and yet a thousand
americans are dying a day and we're
going to look at some record case
numbers later on in the program today we
seem to be heading for another spike the
only question is
how big will it be
um it's been how many generations since
the civil war
and we still have i mean conservatively
some tens of millions of americans who
believe the civil war was not about
preserving slavery they've fallen for
that
and that's hundreds of years ago and on
and on and on
a huge portion of americans believe
demonstrably untrue things and yet we
laugh at russia that some people have
fallen for decades of kremlin propaganda
or we we laugh at north korea now
there's one other layer to this
which is that in many of these countries
let me see how i can say this
in the u.s
there's really no
repercussion to admitting you believe a
lot of this stuff all you know
occasionally there will be
sort of like social consequences you'll
be laughed at and if what you say is
really really
vile you might lose your job but
generally speaking in the u.s if people
believe trump won the 2020 election
they'll just say it
in countries like russia and north korea
to some degree
the people even if they don't believe
this stuff are more likely to say that
they do because the repercussions can be
more serious for saying i don't believe
what the government's telling me
so in reality
it may actually be worse in the united
states and what i mean by that is when
you ask people in russia and north korea
and china whatever else do you believe
this thing some of the people who say
yes are saying it to stay on the good
side of the government which is not
really a factor here in the united
states so as much as we point and say
how do they believe this stuff
it's probably a worse problem here in
the united states this next video is
very much worth watching
republicans
seem to be unable to get the hell away
from this afpak group and conference
led by uh white nationalist nick fuentes
and we talked a couple weeks ago i think
it was about marjorie taylor green
speaking at the afpac conference then
being told you realize it's a white
nationalist group right she said i
didn't know about that i was just there
because it's young people with energy
and enthusiasm okay
but it's happening to many republicans
and there are now calls for resignation
for the idaho lieutenant governor
mcgeechen this is a janice mcgeechen she
also
spoke at the afpac conference and this
is really really good she was
interviewed by ktvbs reporter brian
holmes
and he really did a good job holding her
to account she tries saying i didn't
know anything about the white
nationalist stuff and then he says well
but so so you're saying you didn't even
investigate it she gets into a pickle
and she ultimately walks away this is
really good stuff let's take a look are
you familiar with who puts this event on
like nick fuentes
i don't i don't know who he is i don't
i've never met him i don't know who he
is did you not look into it before you
decided to say okay like to find out i
mean his name is on it right
well you know what nick fuentes i don't
as i said i don't know him i don't he's
never
i've never met him i don't know you know
what
what is what he's
everything that he says or does now
every every conference that i have uh
spoken at
i don't meet the organizers often
but there's no way in hell that i'm
going without doing some serious
research into who's putting this on and
i've turned down many conferences not
because i personally met or knew the
organizer but because i knew what the
conference stood for and i didn't think
that it was a place that i should be
appearing um this gets really good and
really intense say it is not
uh does not reflect on who i am or who
the thousands of others that are
participating in this
movement
he didn't bother to look up his name or
i didn't say that
you did look him up
you didn't that's not the question that
you asked me he just asked it though
did you look up who nick fuentes was and
what he he what he's talked about like
what he thinks he has said
i have since
since
last week not before yes
okay i guess the question is because you
if you've said well i'm only and it's
not fair
i mean you the mainstream media
you do this to conservatives all the
time
but you don't do it to yourself that
every time anytime there's any kind of
affiliation with anybody at any time on
any stage that we're all guilty by
association really i mean i don't
remember people taking this approach
when barack obama's character was
assailed because what was it 18 years
before
he went to
was it bill ayers i don't even remember
the names of the characters at this
point but i think it was he was
associated with bill ayers or some
church or pastor something nobody was
saying well come on and that was 18
years prior what they're talking about
here was two weeks ago and it's not it's
not appropriate but the association
is not a good one
to be associated with people who are
anti-semitic
stop stop excuse me excuse me yes hello
you asked me why
i was there why i wanted to participate
and she's desperate to control
she wants to just keep answering
one question
and control what it is she's expected to
answer
and
it's really a very good job that
the reporter here is doing and it's not
like brian holmes is i mean he's doing a
great job he's not doing anything
particularly unusual he's just asking
very direct questions to these young
conservatives that's that's what we're
talking about right now yeah okay
uh vincent james is also there
correct do you know who vincent james is
i i've i've heard of him you've had your
picture taken with him
i did have my picture taken with him
okay do you know what he stands for and
things that he has said no i don't know
all the things that
he or anybody else and again i'm just
going to keep repeating the same thing
that
this guilt by association that the media
tries to do with conservatives and
conservatives only that is a lie
is that if we ever have met somebody
once or took a picture with them or ever
shared a stage with somebody ever
ever we're all guilty by association now
understand what she did there it is very
different to share a stage in a debate
setting where the subject matter is
that's a white nationalist
i disagree with them and i'm making that
clear
then simply accepting a speaking gig at
a white nationalist conference those are
two those are not equivalent in any way
sharing a stage isn't actually the issue
here but she knows that if you want to
know
why i went there and why what my message
was go go watch my video i did watch
your video and if you would that's what
it was all about if you know who nick
fuentes is would you have said yes
well again this this
this movement is so much bigger than one
individual who cares what nick fuentes
has to say who cares
there's thousands and thousands of young
conservatives all across the country
that are very concerned and
about what's happening to our country
she's really fumbling here and it's
delightful we are fighting for the soul
of our nation with these wide open
borders it's only a matter of time that
america we lose who we are as a free
country and so and i'm not going to run
away i'm not going to hide from being
being
willing and wanting to go talk to young
conservatives about these issues if you
say nobody cares what nick fuentes says
but people care that you're associated
with them or that you share a stage
again you're trying to you're trying to
do this guilt by association over and
over and over again and it needs to stop
because if you want to know who i am and
why i went there i told you that and you
know my
don't assassinate
me or my character
over something that any individual that
i may ever have met in my life
if there are things that again that's a
red herring too just because you once
met someone with a vile view is
different than accepting a speaking
invitation from someone whose movement
is what that is
are said or that they believe in then
that's that person that's not me but
that's not the first time my point bring
up vincent james right i mean that's not
the first time you've been associated
with the with this group and she just
walks away mid-interview there we go she
she was done with it so this entire
guilt by association thing number one if
you keep associating with horrible
people by choice and then sort of say
well i didn't know but then when you're
asked had you known would you have not
gone then you say well no like she's
kind of saying i would have gone anyway
because i was speaking to the
conservatives there who are concerned or
whatever first of all they keep
associating with absolutely vile people
and secondly they do the guilt by
association thing they did it to obama
they do it to anyone who's ever even met
a communist or or socialist i think
better said since communists are quite
rare in the us um and they
they do it with black lives matter they
find one person is it this is black
lives matter they do it with antifa they
do it all the time uh very very nice job
there by brian holmes and we'll have the
clips up on our instagram at david
pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so donald trump has essentially ruled
out that mike pence would be his vice
presidential running mate if he were to
run for president again in 2024 and this
is not particularly surprising given
the last 14 months of the things that
donald trump has said about mike pence
but it does make 2024 significantly more
interesting um a president running again
after losing re-election with a
different running mate is
interesting and this we have learned um
thanks to an interview that donald trump
gave to the washington examiner earlier
this week washington examiner uh writing
trump now in this i know washington
examiner is not what we typically use as
a source but this is the primary source
here this was an interview that they did
trump says pence partnership over as
ex-president eyes 2024 comeback bid
former president donald trump is
effectively ruling out ruling out
tapping former vp mike pence as his
running mate should he mount a third
white house bid in 2024 and win the
republican nomination quote i don't
think the people would accept it
trump told the washington examiner
tuesday evening during a telephone
interview that he gave from mar-a-lago
the former president cited friction
stemming from the aftermath of the 2020
election it's funny to call it friction
you tried to get the guy to do something
illegal
describing that as friction is
interesting suggesting their differences
are too stark to overcome i would agree
with that
trump claimed the contest was stolen and
wanted pence to overturn the results
during the congressional certification
of biden's victory he can't
pence who in his capacity as senate
president was presiding over the
certification proceedings refused
explaining the constitution granted him
no authority it's interesting to call it
a refusal it's really an inability he
can't do it he can't do it now as the
article says and as trump said
trump continues to insist otherwise he
pointed to bipartisan talks on capitol
hill to reform the electoral count act
the law governing the congressional
certification we've talked about that
already
trump said mike and i had a great
relationship except for the very
important factor that took place at the
end we had a very good relationship i
haven't spoken to him in a long time
now there's a couple different things uh
that that can be talked about here first
we're upping the uniqueness uniqueness
factor in some sense because if trump
runs he would also run he will have run
after losing
and pick a different vp it'll be
interesting from like a historical
perspective
i also
can't
avoid saying that the danger factor
would likely be greater because trump
could pick someone that might be more
assertive
and more dangerous and more useful to
him trump is
reportedly mad at florida governor ron
desantis right now but imagine if trump
partnered up with desantis who is
much more delusional than pence in a
particular way and i would argue much
more assertive and able to get things
done
pence
has
conceded that
he didn't have the ability to overturn
the election and that was a nice enough
to put him on trump's naughty list now
for mike pence's part
he was on maria bartoromo's fox business
show not that long ago on march 8th and
she asked him about what are you
thinking for 24 do you want to see trump
run and here's how pence answered it mr
vice president before you go
a word on 2024 do you want president
trump to run are you looking to get back
into leadership
you know all of my focus right now is on
2022 i think we have a historic
opportunity
to reclaim majorities in the house and
the senate to elect great republican
governors around america and in 2023 i'm
i'm confident the republican party will
nominate a candidate who will be
the next president of the united states
of america and at the right time
my family and i will reflect and
consider how we might participate
in that process but yeah so not really
answering the question i think of note
or how the betting markets are looking
at this so far if you look that predict
it
right now
39 cents of every dollar are being bet
on trump being the republican nominee
very close at this point 27 cents of
every dollar are behind ron desantis
being the republican nominee and
in a pretty distant fourth place are six
cents on the dollar
behind mike pence being
the eventual republican nominee i think
there is almost no chance in hell that
mike pence ends up as the republican
nominee but needless to say
it'll be an interesting 2024.
um
i want to talk about post-modernism a
little bit with you guys
one of the i am going to uh suggest to
you today
that
the
often misunderstood
postmodernism
that the right assigns to the american
left
is actually something that we can
correctly ascribe to the right and i'm
going to give you some examples here now
let's back up a little bit
one of the criticisms that the right
loves to make about the left is the
left's woke
postmodernism means
anything goes
everybody's opinions are equally valid
everybody deserves an equal seat at any
table we must listen they say the left
says we must listen to any hair brained
crazy idea no matter how uh
unsubstantiated or unbacked up not
backed up it is by empiricism and data
or whatever and that's how the left gets
into these crazy things that they end up
getting into like uh you know all the
different things they talk about and
some of the things we've talked about
right like uh jewish women aren't
intersectional enough to lead the
women's march or whatever the case may
be
now
does that exist on the left to some
degree well yeah it's it's a very very
small thing on the left
but i would argue
that this is a much bigger deal on the
right where when the right says
you really can't trust the media
and some
guy with a mic
on real america's voice
is
at least potentially just as trustworthy
as actual investigative journalism that
is doing real investigative journalism
or for example
scientists specialists public health
experts
they don't necessarily know what's going
on
some preacher offering you drinkable
silver
or
some dude on the internet who's
vaporizing uh hydrogen peroxide all of
these things are equally likely to be
the proper way to deal with covid or my
sister's stepmom's brother's aunts
adopted babysitter
is just as good of a resource on
vaccines as
a doctor
that is actually the place where you see
this anything goes as long as it's
convenient type of stuff and look at
this example
here is now you might have been
unaware
that the trucker convoy is kind of like
still i guess going on and some
republicans have invited the truckers to
meet with them
and here is video of a convoy truck lee
a trucker convoy leader
saying to republican congressman jim
jordan listen
the truckers know what's going on with
covet covet is over and truckers are the
new scientist and jim jordan loves it
this
is the very caricature of anything goes
post-modernism that they ascribe to the
left look at this
so yeah we the the country's figured it
all out you know yeah they appreciate
the fact that you're you're standing up
and saying the first event it matters i
mean the trumpers becomes a scientist
for america now in the world and there's
no science across the world and these
ladies cannot test it that
supports any of the mandates or the
underlying emergency declarations there
is no data or science
covert is done
and the american people understand this
omicron was our off ramp
governments need to be bold and grab
over crown and take this exit strategy
yeah sadly enough it takes the trucker
to now stand up as
a scientist right the truckers this
country is going down the tubes but
truckers
doing the work of scientists are what is
going to save us
this is the very
it's a caricature
of the very post-modernism that they
claim to oppose
there's other examples of this
bryce mitchell the ufc fighter last week
i played a clip of bryce mitchell saying
i don't know what's going on in russia
and ukraine and then giving 10
unsubstantiated opinions and conspiracy
theories and tucker carlson brings him
on as someone to be listened to remember
this this is the same thing guys
everybody gets an equal seat at the
table ufc fighter trucker on matters of
geopolitics and epidemiology why the
hell not honored to have bryce mitchell
join us tonight bryce thanks so much for
coming on and for what you said
i haven't seen anybody express it better
than you did why did you say that
well thank you so much for having me
brother and i said that because that's
the first thing that i thought when he
asked me and i was trying to give him
the best answer that i could and that's
just my genuine thoughts on the subject
how do you get to be so honest when
everyone everyone else is afraid to say
what they think and you just kind of say
it
well i don't have to be
worried about being fired from my job
for saying what i want to say there's a
lot of people out there that do agree
with me but they can't say things that i
get to say even though they thank them
his explanation for how he's coming up
with all this stuff doesn't really
matter but again
they say the left has this anything goes
sort of idea but it is they who are
actually doing exactly that and then
lastly madison cawthorne and again
guy knows absolutely nothing about
foreign policy or anything and it has
worked on the right here is a guy at one
of his town halls actually saying can
you explain russia and ukraine to me
yeah anybody else
yeah congressman yes sir
we got this mess in the
eastern europe there with ukraine and
all that i know you've made some
reference to
president zielinski being the thug or
being
you know in the government being corrupt
we're all i think we're all trying to
figure this thing out i mean
it seems like we're on the precipice of
a could be a possible major disaster can
you clarify some of that for us so we
know where we stand with that uh i will
so
one and again we already looked at
madison cawthorne's answer it's whacked
it's outrageously critical of zelensky
it attacks ukraine and does all these
different things doesn't matter the
specifics don't matter but the point is
the right loves to ascribe this exact
type of listen this person is an expert
or whatever maybe
we
why do you why is a blue-haired feminist
explaining gender when that's not really
you need a doctor i guess to explain sex
and gender or whatever but then they've
got madison cawthron explaining
geopolitics they've got bryce mitchell
ufc fighter explaining foreign relations
and they've got the truckers acting as
scientists
it's absurd and we can't allow them to
get away with accusing the left of doing
exactly what it is that they do every
single day
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month
check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show well my
friends i hate to have to do this to you
again i really do i i wish that things
were different than they are
but unfortunately what we talked about
at the start of this week as far as the
virus is concerned the pandemic
um it seems to be coming true and we're
going to go through the data and and
again
i want this to be over as much as
everyone and i have like many of us
started to go back to just a more normal
pre-pandemic way of living
and all of it i'm with everybody on this
stuff
but
we have to talk about things as they are
and not as we wish that they would be
and earlier this week i told you we're
starting to see a little bit of an
uptick
in some european countries in some asian
countries and in all likelihood at some
point this is going to come here to the
united states and then we're going to
have to figure out how bad is this going
to get
and how deadly is this going to be
and all of the questions we've all been
exhaustingly grappling with now for two
years plus a week we're basically
two years plus a week i guess you'd call
it 105 weeks into this pandemic in some
way shape or form and there are some
very ugly numbers from yesterday we'll
put these up on the screen for people
who are watching today
in south korea
going all the way back to the start of
the pandemic
more cases than ever in one day
yesterday
not in 2020 not in 2021 the worst day
for new cases in south korea was
yesterday with about 400
000 new cases that is an ugly chart
imagine a really steep mountain
so steep that you'd fall off of it if
you tried to climb it that's what the
cases look like in south korea
if you're listening today in germany a
very big spike to the point where
germany now
on an average seven day average
is at the highest point of the pandemic
now averaging about 210
000 cases a day south korea and germany
very different countries but we are
seeing the same thing happen
in vietnam uh just an unbelievable spike
now regularly logging 175
000 new covet cases per day ugly ugly
ugly it makes the first year and a half
of the pandemic looked like there were
no cases in vietnam
because of how high the numbers are now
france although france had a disastrous
omicron wave so the numbers are nowhere
near that yet but
other than the omicron spike
france is also experiencing average
daily cases now higher than the first
second and third spikes
in the uk which has been a big leading
indicator i i don't know that there's
any country that has better predicted
what happens in the u.s
than the uk throughout the pandemic the
uk's daily case numbers are now back up
to about 60 70 000 cases per day
and there's a question as to whether
that's as high as it's going to go or
whether it's going to continue climbing
italy which remember at the very
beginning italy had one of the worst
spikes that spike when we now look back
looks like nothing it look it looks
almost completely flat in april of 2020
and that was outdone in november of 2020
and of course overwhelmingly outdone by
the omicron spike italy is now higher
than at any point other than the omicron
spike
these are really really ugly numbers now
let's kind of talk through
what's the most disastrous
interpretation well some of that we're
seeing in a number of different articles
uh one such article in stat news with
infection spiking in europe and a
variant on the rise experts warned the
u.s could face a coveted resurgence and
of course we don't know how bad it could
get we're still seeing a thousand people
a day die so could that get back up to
two thousand three thousand
it's a question mark and obviously the
hope is no the hope would be no now
some of you might be saying wait and i
haven't heard of a new variant
this is kind of a sub-variant of omicron
omicron was called the ba1 variant we're
now seeing ba2 it's not its own unique
variant in a sense it's part of the same
omicron lineage and it from what we know
right now and i always want to be
careful from what we know as of right
now
it is
equivalent to omicron in terms of
severity but it seems to be more
contagious so it's not its own variant
but it is
a version of omicron so that that's kind
of that's that's
a pessimistic or more alarmist reaction
um nbc news reporting on what the who
now says who says global rise in coveted
cases is only the tip of the iceberg
after more than a month of decline
global coveted cases rose last week with
the biggest jump in the western pacific
region which includes south korea and
china and of course the question is
when if and when this is coming to the
united states now let's i i will now
give you the more optimistic
interpretation which is the one i'm
hoping for
and that would be
we've seen some other countries get
through the ba2 variant already they had
their omicron spike and their they had
their it's sometimes called stealth
omicron or ba2 spike and it was a spike
but it was relatively short and it again
declined quickly
that would be the hope for the united
states
the reason we might be less optimistic
in the united states is we only have i i
don't remember now if it's 26 or 28
percent of the population
who has had three doses and as we
learned during the omicron spike that
third dose
very very um effective
at mitigating the uh impact of omicron
we've learned that the two doses are not
great when it comes to omicron we've
also learned that a fourth dose based on
the data from the first omicron spike
the fourth dose dose didn't really seem
to do much to help with omicron
so three you know it's
this this bowl of porridge is too cold
this bowl of porridge is too hot
whatever um so
the the hope would be
that um
as more people get that third dose that
we would end up with a ba2 spike that is
not
that that bad analysis from the uk
health security agency shows the ba2
subvariant of omicron is about 80
percent more contagious than ba1
and ba1 is the original omicron
variant cases
and hospitalizations are rising in the
uk
and in a number of other countries so
that's we we've said before
we might get to a point where cases
don't really matter
if hospitalizations don't go up as well
unfortunately in some of these european
countries we're seeing not only cases
rise but also hospitalization so we will
continue following it and obviously
hoping for the best
this is super interesting um yesterday
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky spoke to
the u.s house and the u.s senate and as
i said earlier made a number of requests
for equipment
and we've already talked about how joe
biden is sending some additional
equipment to ukraine but at least for
the time being
not getting involved in creating or
enforcing a no-fly zone and one of the
fascinating things to see has been the
right-wing media tear itself apart about
how they're supposed to react to this
and it's uh there's sort of two sides to
this and both want to criticize joe
biden just understand that they they all
want to slam biden
but they're at odds as to why it's sort
of like the flat earthers where we've
said before all of the flat earthers
agree the earth is flat
but often the defenses they give
conflict with each other so one story
that some in the right-wing media are
telling is biden's bad because he's not
giving zolensky what he wants zolensky
is asking for all this stuff we should
be sending it to zielenski biden's not
giving zelensky everything he wants so
biden is a disaster for for that reason
okay
another story from other members in the
right-wing media is russia and putin
really aren't that bad
ukraine's bad and we really shouldn't be
helping them very much so biden's bad
because he has sent military assistance
to ukraine
that's a conflict right they both say
biden's bad one says biden's bad for not
giving ukraine enough stuff the other
says biden's bad for giving stuff to
ukraine and it was
made
front and center last night on fox news
sean hannity invoked ronald reagan in
his monologue to support
sending more to ukraine than what biden
has sent
laura ingram invoked reagan in her
monologue to say we should not be
sending stuff to ukraine it's
fascinating look at this take a look at
this clip from last night bad actors we
should learn the lessons from reagan
give zelinski what he's asking for the
weapons that they need so they can
battle back against russia the ukrainian
people reagan won the cold war by
rebuilding our economy and growing our
military which took a few years after
the devastation we faced under carter
the same pattern will have to play out
here
now as the angle is said from the
beginning the situation in ukraine
is a horrific tragedy it breaks all of
our hearts
but we have to be prudent and we have to
be thoughtful in our response
and right now the us is simply in no
good position to engage in another
protracted military struggle
we need time to repair our economy
reform our military and get political
leadership that actually works is good
is smart
whatever happens we cannot repeat the
same mistakes we made after 9 11.
so that's just fascinating hannity says
the lesson from reagan
is we've got to arm them
and laura ingram says the lesson from
reagan is we shouldn't arm them and of
course it all is in service of their
overarching narrative which is biden's
bad they agree biden's bad but for
different reasons and laura ingram spent
most of last night pushing back on on
sending equipment to ukraine and of
course it's a legitimate position to
take that we shouldn't send stuff to
ukraine reasonable people can disagree
about that perfectly fine conversation
to have for them it's all in service to
attacking biden here's laura ingram
pushing back on
the fighter jets uh debate to attack joe
biden to be where president zielinski
urged him to be today which is leading
the world in helping ukraine fight for
their own freedom well biden can't lead
the united states senator cotton with
all due respect i mean when i hear about
when i hear president
biden being told you need to lead the
world first of all you know with all due
respect to you know president zielinski
is obviously incredibly heroic
you know
he he's fighting for his country as he
should but we have a president who's as
i said in the angle essentially a
hologram
he is not an active president defending
our interests here let alone the
president of the world
so i mean i think going down that road
is kind of ridiculous at this point
so there's laura ingraham uh and one
more laura ingram clip here she says
isn't all of this that we're sending to
ukraine just going to give them false
hope and they're just going to lose
anyway in many cases i mean just look
today they announced the transfer of 800
million dollars of weapons to ukraine
this welcome should have been done a
month ago or two months ago and it's
still just a fraction of what congress
proposed last week look the ukrainian
people and army have proven that they
are capable of fighting the russians we
need to encourage them to do so and we
need to provide the weapons that they
need to fight the russians now you don't
think you don't think we're giving
the ukrainians at this point and the
rest of the world false hope you think
that you think given the fact that
russia is closing in on ukraine at this
moment you heard the air raid sirens
outside of la viv
okay so you get it isn't aren't we just
giving them false hope by giving them
stuff and then lastly here's laura
ingram reacting to mitt romney saying
send them what they are asking for
people are dying send them the planes
that they need they want migs get them
the migs
why don't you pay for them
now did he ever stop to think
that more people could die if we send
ukraine migs so there is well it's
actually going to be worse if we send
stuff now again
there is a legitimate conversation about
to what degree should the united states
be involved here either individually
or as part of nato that is a fair debate
but it is fascinating to see number one
objective is biden bad that's the
primary goal here
some right wingers justifying it in one
way
other right wingers justifying it in a
way that directly conflicts but biden
definitely is bad that they're very sure
of
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p here's a really funny
voicemail i have a new nickname my new
nickname is bookboy and i have to tell
you it's not really an insult i wish
more people read books i kind of like
this take a listen
hey bookboy what's going down have you
figured out street smarts yet right the
government's doing
i have a question for you please what is
your interpretation
or your understanding of democracy
because
i'm getting different answers from
everybody i mean in a super simple way i
would say
democracy
is when
the will of the people
is
for is able to be expressed
and act and is acted on by our
representatives i mean i you know the a
lot of these right-wingers love to have
us define terms like when i was on with
jesse lee peterson
he said what is love
what is a man and i told him i don't
know i don't really do dictionary
definitions but i i guess in some way
it's uh the a system in which the
desires of the people are freely
expressed and then um acted on by our
elected officials i i don't know it's
very maybe that's quaint do you
understand what democracy is and what
the [ __ ] is supposed to be going on with
that
i don't think so
i don't think so
the government does not run this country
big business does
okay that's why
they legalize lobbyists
and i mean listen he's not wrong about
the outsized influence of big business
for sure he can pay
for any congressman or any senator they
want to
do you honestly think
that we're being served
as a country
through this government and if you do
then you're naive
so here's the thing
this guy is making it about
this particular government the systemic
problems with american government
haven't changed because biden won and
trump lost and i'm right there with them
but the idea that there's something
particularly pernicious about the biden
administration now there's no evidence
for that whatsoever we've got a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about a court ordering actor jesse
smallett released from jail during his
appeal we will talk about the new 125
million dollar demand from former cnn
host chris cuomo he says he was
wrongfully terminated
we will talk about that and lastly
netflix is testing a new feature
to fight against password sharing
yeah we will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com i'll see you
then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman